I think what I think we should go back
and do the whole clone wars together all
right that's okay what is going on there
citizens of the reject Nation we are
back for bad bachelor's is forward five
four episode four no five because the
first one had two so it was five three
four you know how to count Greg
Michael's here with me today that's
right Michael bring in the Star Wars
knowledge but not let us down again
ladies and gentlemen use the force to
leave a like so I did that I love that I
also use the force to take your your
stroller or your phone and subscribe and
click the notification Bell and if if
you're not if you're not on the real
rejects patreon you want to go home and
rethink your life because yeah we got
full length Reaction watch alongs for
here and follow Michael tesler on social
media
multihouse.io it's also their website
they produce content that is going to
revolutionize the film industry and it's
all as always Star Wars inspired yeah a
thousand percent let's watch this
Michael
[Music]
come on title
entombed interesting yeah probably gonna
beat a cave setting
[Music]
I love a good junkyard
armor that's going on here it's Rusty
Bear compressor here among other things
you got that right
look at all this crap
[Music]
I'm gonna find little fetus Ray hanging
around
[Music]
do you think you can't see it from that
eye I don't think so she's turned into a
flashlight
I had no choice but to fend off the
octomorph bear head
octomorphone you know what I found
what would you find
sweat it out only the Grand Prix of
Novak
those two believe anything
Phil we haven't seen hunter in Forever
hang on
does it open
these look like coordinate markings
[Laughter]
these coordinates are in the caldar
trinary system have no record of that
system the best Treasures usually aren't
found on maps treasure there
this Compass is a rare five a rare find
check it out you heard V
she says a lot of things
we do need an episode of the week I
agree or maybe this will be more
important that's the life of a treasure
hunter
don't you mean pirate I prefer Liberator
of ancient wonders
[Laughter]
they tend to throw down a lot further
establishing shots don't they they sure
do the bigger budget than all of Clone
Wars season one
[Music]
planet looks like it was glassed or
something I'm not picking up any signs
of civilization whatsoever this land
appears to have been raised and left
uninhabitable
excellent treasure here
the compass just activated
got a bad feeling about this
what do you think they're gonna find
feel like there has to be some kind of
Jedi or Sith
maybe we go around the mountain
round the mountain we go
telling us to go inside
perhaps a certain Wayward youngling you
think they're gonna find a person
I don't know maybe
there could be some artifacts of big guy
help me move this
holocron type significance she bit her
hand in there like she was force
sensitive did you see that
that would be an interesting plot twist
the minds of Moria speak friend
who's your package
[Music]
it's a flaming rain call
flaming rank or
I'd watch it that'd be cool interest way
to scar them all
what
every pirate out there has heard the
legend of Scar and all I'll explain it
like no Shadow what kind of treasures in
there the heart of the mountain
and we're going to liberate it
smoke
[Laughter]
yeah
real Lord of the Rings Vibes wreck on
the Temple of Doom
better
some Raiders of the Lost Ark Vibes the
symbols in the right order
oh my God it's like my favorite
Uncharted levels
line this [__] up
God of War does a lot of that too oh
yeah and Zelda
might just be a gaming Motif what if
only they made Star Wars games
[Music]
nope booby traps that was getting
interesting
trapped Us in here
relax they're into always a way out we
just have to find tuned
yeah once you get to the end it's like
right next to the entrance
[Music]
omega's like the little sibling playing
a video game finding all the yeah yeah
my Lantern
[Music]
some such epic music right
they better find something insane in
here with him out of emphasis they're
putting on the food because there is
that Indiana Jones swashbuckling vibe
so I quit doing this
my interest has suddenly peaked
come on say it Hunter what exactly is
the head of the mountain a rare
crystalline Stone some say is the key to
an agent power the Arkenstone
foreign
[Music]
no I don't like it
it's like straight out of alien they're
a smaller side tunnels throughout
then we'll keep looking for the treasure
they'll be fine come on
Fortune awaits
I don't trust her can't trust a bloody
pirate she just knows a little too much
for my liking we need to keep moving
look out for booby traps
[Music]
oh
I think the way to walk
my thoughts exactly
you're just making this up as you go
we have almost died three times already
this reminds me of the time I tracked
down the Belmont diet I don't care
[Music]
wow cool that's super cool I feel like
this episode is foreshadowing what
omega's Adventures are going to be after
this show hmm
or clear
the compass
can't get it served its purpose his car
in laws reclaimed it
ah snyra now has reclaimed it
[Laughter]
omega's like that anime character who
just repeats everything
yeah something ahead is
with my scans
Roger Rogers too
in your head maybe we shouldn't dismiss
him we all saw it it almost killed you
it's not very nice
type of puzzle is this
don't overthink it brown eyes sometimes
the doors
just the door just the door
the writers on this episode were like ah
I got nothing
it's just a bunch of video game homages
I love it
[Music]
what if she just disintegrates when she
picks it up
oh man they're probably gonna have to
start running giant ball yeah get out of
there get out of there oh please be an
actual giant ball it's also a bit of
Aladdin Vibes um yeah
rub the lamp rub the lamp
whoa
Skyping
all right maybe it is Halo
what is happening Bell Rock
is it good
is that a ship
it looks like Mecca Godzilla
then what is it good question
this is some cool stuff right here
wow it is like a Mechagodzilla
oh is that what destroyed the planet in
the first place
if removing the heart of the mountain
activated it perhaps we must return it
to its proper place deactivate no no
well Brussels
[Music]
if that thing destroys it we'll be
trapped on this planet
all right but you owe me
oh you
why yikes
I wonder what it says on there
[Music]
oh
he's just trying really hard to prove
he's not racist
what
is this creature I love it
oh did they just kill off Mel
is that thing metal protected too I
think it's organic no I think it's just
a shell
[Music]
it's interesting it just destroys
anything it sees I know it doesn't it
seems like it's sentient at the same
time must be like a Proto Droid
foreign
to the mountain yeah I don't know I
think this might be it for it
but it wasn't shaped like that before
damn this is crazy [__]
dead
just a flesh wound I'll be fine
this puts us at over two in treasure
hunting even with a professional did
find the heart of the mountain the
legend was it was real
that's the right attitude
we wasted our time kill the Droid we
helped destroy a planet even more at
least no one can ever activate that
thing again it's a good thing we came
after all
this happens all the time that's why I
keep Mel's memory stored on my ship's
Data Bank no ah well we head to
Veterinary what's on vet name
I have a lead on a certain chalice very
ancient Oh Holy Grail
Legend has it the Chalice once belonged
to the kingdom of elways lost over a
millennia ago
he actually seems a little Charmed oh
this is
a little spark A Little Romance
take it away Michael well we had our
first filler episode of the Season uh
one might argue not filler
explain that argument
we learned that maybe they shouldn't be
Pirates and treasure Hunters
um no it was it was fun I mean it was it
was nice to see some inspiration from a
lot of other Lucas properties definitely
some heavy Indiana Jones I feel like
that was like a uh a not so not so uh
huddle humble you're trying to say uh
Nazi huddle
anyway
[Laughter]
um no I I thought it was it was fun I
mean it was a bit of Indiana Jones uh
there was a bit of Lord of the Rings
there is a bit of alien alien yeah pop
and I was like hey it's black oh that's
such a good point
um uh Halo I mean there's a lot of video
game influences on this particular
episode
um which was fun even them like solving
the puzzles was just I think you and I
were both in our heads like oh no you
gotta move that around and you know yeah
um but it was it was fun it was it was
cool to see some like you know
Old Republic era crazy Tech maybe even
like pretty Old Republic I like the
design of that and the you know we
there's there's that Trope where like
you you think you've walked into a
mountain or some part under the ground
and then ends up like rising up like
wait we're in a creature even Empire
Strikes Back does that with uh when the
Millennium Falcon is uh getting away
with the chase yeah so yeah that is uh
it is a Trope in general but it's it's a
cool and a nice reveal and I like the
flip that attraction in some type of
Mecca monster thing it's very Mecha
Godzilla yeah and the design of it was
super I mean it was it was nice because
it was very warm the world exactly it
was very unfamiliar to Star Wars but
um it was nice it felt ancient and weird
um you know it was fun getting to see
the batch together again
um
fee hasn't done anything for me yet as a
character
um I
I I love Wanda Sykes uh but I'm sure as
we figure her out more it'll be
multi-house is racist
no no uh you know like the whole bad
batch isn't white Greg did you get that
memo in fact none of the Clones are uh
but uh new zealanders
um yeah so
not Cortez racing
not New Zealander
is a Pacific Pacific like Samoan uh
something like that they're all Pacific
Islanders yeah so they identify us oh
the Camino wins
Pacifica we have cloned Pacific
Islanders
feet
um Greg is a good person I promise I'm
really setting you up now I'm talking
about you man not my beliefs chewy is
the best character no she's of all time
I'm excited to see where her story goes
um this episode definitively makes me
think that
um she might be our direct connection to
Hondo who if Hondo doesn't come back
soon I'm gonna protest
um I I think this episode was setting up
something else that could come down the
road would be an Omega uh specifically I
don't feel like you know it's easy to
disregard this as ah it's just a filler
maybe it will be there's also like 48
episodes in a season of the bad batch
this is true yeah it's true gotta keep
me employed yeah
there's a lot of there's a lot of
emphasis in the bad batch and something
about specifically with the way Omega
reacts and responds to the situation at
hand and how good she is at figuring out
the clues and also the fact fascination
with treasure hunting in general
no I I think that's that's a great point
from the first episode too you know yeah
I mean even on Serrano like uh it was
the same exact thing
um and I feel like it's it's exciting
to see how easily lead astray
Omega is from the rest of the bad
marriage yeah
um which like given the wrong influence
um can put Omega into a dire situation
uh or conversely the entire bad batch I
mean she's almost got them all killed
like several times many times yeah I've
almost gotten killed just trying to save
her yeah so what does it say about Omega
vote in the comments should she be
booted off the show off the island
but yeah I mean overall I thought the
episode itself was fine uh the like I I
I appreciated more what they were going
for atmospherically yeah I like the
concept that Han and the homages I I
appreciate it from an observant point of
view uh this was out of all the episodes
this was the least emotionally engaged
that I was yeah uh for them all
but I think that's it's probably when
you think about a show that they have as
many episodes as they have and there's
so many critical beats I feel like an
episode like this to just develop what
their chemistry is as a group
is kind of essential but did it for the
I mean perhaps with fee I think a little
bit with fee and
um that's true I mean it really
kind of whatever there yeah I I wanted
it to be more
um I wanted the treasure to have at
least some kind of implication on the
larger plot at hand or but not
everything always has to be that
um it's very Indiana Jones to find the
treasure and then be like never mind
yeah yeah put that in the warehouse
put in a warehouse we'll see it again in
Kingdom of the Christian School I mean
they even talk about the Holy Grail like
you're definitely referencing yeah well
it's another Lucas property which I
think is fun you know I mean if if you
go back and and watch uh Raiders of the
Lost Ark like C-3PO and R2D2 are in the
hieroglyphs like a long a long-standing
history of these properties playing into
each other and that would be cool that
was fun yeah
um yeah well we're not gonna talk
forever about this one because uh of the
status episode but overall still
enjoying season two an awful lot I feel
like the first four episodes were
grandiose and uh this one was uh it's
fine I remember first season was more
like okay first episode good but the
next three have been a little rocky yeah
I think this is kind of like all right
well I'll take your your fifth episode
as the one that is the least engaging
one and it was still fun I mean yeah we
jumped we cried we laughed yeah we did
all those emotions we cried we were in
shock and Terror the entire time we both
looked pretty stupid when it turned out
to be giant Mecca Godzilla can't say I
saw that coming no I I didn't either
um I was hoping that they were gonna get
like a great design a new ship or
something neat out of that but
um alas the only treasure that they
found was The Treasure of friendship and
now somewhere out there another person
can create a new book in the Star Wars
World about this planet and that
creature oh I mean that's what I was
gonna like that you know that's gonna
like I'm sure if we were to read like
the high Republic uh uh content that
it's probably in there in 10 years this
will be the most one of the most
important episodes yeah
it's a prequel to The prequels
and a sequel to
the high Republic yeah and the Old
Republic yeah yeah this planet will
become utmost importance and how it
became to the Decay and the Creator I
think they opened up an interesting
discussion of to theorize on what became
of this and how that thing came to be
thank God for Wikipedia I know yeah you
can just ask [__] on there
it's just it's just me at night yeah
freaking Havoc yeah yeah wrecker is
actually The Reincarnation of an ancient
Sith Lord all right guys all right well
thank you for being here
Michael
your Star Wars Easter eggs were okay
this time there wasn't there wasn't a
lot to work with I Blame You they gave
me an authorian I liked his his
translator to translate text text in in
real time you got to translate the text
on the screen I I speak basic
well
[Laughter]
all right guys
see you next week see you next week
[Music]